now you can see I'm bringing these
indices right but these are the best
okay um if I said to you if I actually
burn something like this how would you
like verbally how would you read that
out
you'd say n to the power off and then
you just read out whatever numbers there
okay but almost none of you will read
out this in the same way you won't read
that as into the power you'll read that
as and squid now why do you think you'd
do that it's because it's because of
this right what does that look like we
remember higher percent of nd as a that
way and be this way
well surprise surprise and squared is
and this way and and this way that's why
we call it N squared because it's a
square okay so there's n square down the
front how am I going to do the rest of
this what's it gonna look like how would
you tour to end yeah okay now you can
see if I did too that would be just I'm
gonna walk in one little block but
actually this is 2n so it can be too
high like that okay but it's gonna be
why isn't it how why is it going to be
it's gonna be this one right the same
width I had before so it's gonna look
like this that's still air and that's -
did you see can't arrange it you can
kind of fish this off right I'm gonna
add to it another rectangle to look like
this this is an and this is three yeah
last one what do you want to put on the
end
I'm just gonna do two more squares right
because it says two and square you I'm
just gonna do one another one now as I
pointed out just like early on right
our initial air and he would be like to
say 12 bags that's a very common carrier
to make it the beginning yeah like look
at this mess it's a bit of a disaster
right now we teach you we train you to
say that these things are different to
these things can you see why they're
different yes this look this squares and
these are like weird funny things okay
so they don't fit that's why we don't
collect them what is this now remember I
said to you simple idea powerful
application we can simplify this by
collecting my terms
another thing you could be asked to do
after this is to factorize it
how would you factorize this answer what
could you take out then you could take
out an end right what would that leave
you with in the brackets 3i plus 1 right
okay not just pause what would that look
like what does that look like
one and two and three ends plus one
do you see it and write this the
factorization what factorizing means is
put together whatever rectangles and
sway as you can as long as they match up
like this there's the end there's the
three n plus 1 right because I just took
these three jammed up on the top when
you take these two away you only get
everyone so that's why it's hanging out
there on the bottom I'm gonna do one
more example for you know I tell y know
y'all will do more because I'm running
out of space example 4 okay now again
I'm trying to make you think before you
leap to an odd song right we'll link to
the answer in a second but don't you
think about what it means this
I'm contending I can draw with squares
and rectangles how am I gonna do it
yeah okay so here's the way I'm going to
approach it right the first thing is I
know what that looks like right I've
actually drawn that kind of several
times today N squared is going to look
like that is it square and then three
are you a free thinker history but just
like over here how it's like oh there's
a rectangle but now I want three of them
three of those rectangles how many
rectangles like this am I going to have
and the answer is I'm gonna have n of
them right now
watch this I'm gonna draw another look
here I'm gonna doctor doc cuz I actually
don't know how many n is it could be 50
it could be 100 it could be just one I
don't know so I'm just gonna draw dots
to indicate I don't know how many now
here's the thing I want you to combine
these things together in some way okay
let's do the easy bit first M times
three that's these guys right what's
that gonna look what haven't I already
drawn it on the boy is right there do
you see why because what I've done is
I've taken all of these guys and then
I've just lined them up one two three
four however many until this end of them
so I'll draw that guy first ok so
there's the free end okay what happens
when you put all of them together now
the thing is I don't know what any is
but if this is a square this is really
square and I put together the same
number of squares as the width is world
is one thing I know about squares when
you take what say it was for right if
you take one and then you put it
together with two and then you prove
together with three and then you've got
four which is n of them what's that it's
n cubed right cuz we call it cubed we
don't say n to the power of three we
call it n cubed because it's
you that's the name we gift of his shape
so I'm gonna try there he is there's a
cute and